WAS INJURED IN THIS SHOOTING
ATTACK AT DALLAS LOVE FIELD
AIRPORT.
>> ED, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ED LAVENDERA ON THE SCENE FOR
US.
>> CNN IS NOW LEARNING NEW
DETAILS ABOUT THE U.S. RESPONSE
TO THE GROWING MONKEYPOX
OUTBREAK.
SOURCES TELL CNN THE WHITE HOUSE
IS WORKING ON NAMING A MONKEYPOX
COORDINATOR FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE TO THE
VIRUS.
THIS AFTER THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DECLARED IT A
GLOBAL HEALTH EMERGENCY OVER THE
WEEKEND.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH DR. HARRIS,
THE SPOKESPERSON FOR THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
DR. HARRIS, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
THE W.H.O. HAS DECLARED
MONKEYPOX A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AROUND THE WORLD, BUT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
YET TAKEN THAT STEP.
SHOULD IT TAKE THAT STEP?
>> GOOD EVENING, AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME WITH YOU.
WE DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OF INTERNATIONAL
CONCERN, AND WHEN WE DO THAT, WE
DO IT BECAUSE WE SEE AN EVENT
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY, UNUSUAL,
WHERE WE SEE INTERNATIONAL
SPREAD, AND WHERE WE WANT THE
WORLD TO COME TOGETHER IN A
COORDINATED WAY TO HELP STOP
THIS EVENT, TO DEAL WITH THE
EVENT.
NOW, HOW COUNTRIES RESPOND
INDIVIDUALLY IS THEIR DECISION.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS
A COUNTRY WITH A HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSMISSION AND IN OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'RE CERTAINLY
SAYING HAVE A COORDINATING
RESPONSE AND RAISE AWARENESS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
BUT HOW IT'S DEALT WITH IN YOUR
GOVERNMENT IS A DECISION FOR
YOUR GOVERNMENT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS EXPECTED
TO NAME A MONKEYPOX COORDINATOR.
IS THAT STRONG ENOUGH?
IS THAT A STRONG ENOUGH STEP IN
YOUR VIEW?
>> CERTAINLY, THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR, A
COORDINATING RESPONSE.
THAT'S ONE OF OUR TOP
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND MADE ON SATURDAY WHEN THE
DIRECTOR GENERAL DECIDED TO
RAISE OUR HIGHEST ALERT BY
CALLING IT A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OF INTERNATIONAL
CONCERN.
THE OTHER THINGS WE'RE REALLY
ASKING IS THAT WE WORK IN EVERY
COUNTRY WITH AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES AND TAKE LEADERSHIP
FROM THEM, HELP GET THEM TO HELP
US TO COMMUNICATE WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE AND TO FIND WAYS TO
STOP THE TRANSMISSION.
>> THE FORMER U.S. FDA
COMMISSIONER, DR. SCOTT GOTTLIEB
TWEETED THIS.
LET ME PUT IT UP ON THE SCREEN.
IF WE HAVE ALLOWED MONKEYPOX TO
BECOME AN EPIDEMIC IN THE U.S.,
WHICH IS BECOMING AN
INCREASINGLY POSSIBLE OUTCOME,
IT WILL BE AMONG THE MOST
UNFORTUNATE PUBLIC HEALTH
FAILURES IN RECENT TIMES.
ARE WE SEEING A HISTORIC PUBLIC
HEALTH FAILURE UNFOLD,
DR. HARRIS?
>> WE'RE SEEING A VERY UNUSUAL
EVENT.
WE HAVE KNOWN MONKEYPOX SINCE
THE 1970s.
WE FIRST SAW IT IN 1958 IN
MONKEYS ITSELF, EVEN THOUGH IT'S
ACTUALLY OTHER ANIMALS WHO ARE
MORE LIKELY TO TRANSMIT IT, BUT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS LEVEL OF
TRANSMISSION AROUND THE WORLD.
WE NOW HAVE 70 COUNTRIES.
SO LET'S NOT POINT TO ONE
COUNTRY OR ANOTHER COUNTRY.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS WORK
TOGETHER INTERNATIONALLY.
>> 16,836 CASES GLOBALLY SO FAR
CONFIRMED.
THE CDC SAYS THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES GETTING DATA ABOUT
THIS VIRUS.
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO FIX THAT
PROBLEM?
>> SO GETTING DATA THAT'S A
RANGE OF THINGS, BUT CERTAINLY
HAVING PEOPLE COME FORWARD,
HAVING PEOPLE TESTED, HAVING
PEOPLE COME FORWARD FOR
TREATMENT AND TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS WILL
REQUIRE A REDUCTION IN THE KIND
OF STIGMA WE'RE SEEING, THAT
PEOPLE ARE VERY MUCH FOCUSING ON
ONE GROUP.
THIS AFFECTS ALL OF US.
AND THE REASON WE PAY ATTENTION
TO MONKEYPOX IS THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE GROUPS ARE ACTUALLY
CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN AND
IMMUNO SUPPRESSED, AND ANY ONE
OF US CAN GET MONKEYPOX BECAUSE
IT IS SIMPLY SPREAD BY CLOSE
CONTACT, SKIN TO SKIN,
FACE-TO-FACE, WITH SOMEBODY WHO
IS INFECTED.
SO WHAT'S CRITICAL IS SOMEBODY
WHO DOES KNOW THEY'RE INFECTED
IS THAT THEY SEEK HELP AND THEY
ALSO SELF-ISOLATE AND PROTECT
OTHERS WHILE THEY'RE INFECTIOUS.
>> GOOD ADVICE INDEED.